allez maintenant on va continuer
ensemble parce que on s'embrouille savez
c'est mieux avec deux autres élèves qui
nous ont rejoint le sourire de malo et
eden qui sont là tous les deux on s'est
dit bonjour tout à l'heure on peut se
dire bonjour on peut se tutoyer aussi
tous les deux pays
ouais ça va vous êtes en quelques
classes tant qu'elle casse toi l'éden 4e
et toi mal au quatrième ce même collège
oui boris vian mais ce salon mais super
c'est l'avis du talent aussi me racontez
moi votre projet est bien mal aux doigts
on est en 4ème et du coup puisqu'on est
en 4e on peut plus faire un autre album
puisque c'est réservé aux cinquième et
sixième
alors nos professeurs ont décidé qu'on
allait faire un autre projet qui est
aussi intergénérations
l'intergénérationnel ouais et ses
projets sap l eamau une histoire et
c'est un projet où on va lire des
histoires kamishibaï des élèves de cp
pour nous ça nous entraîne alors à la
notamment de problèmes progrès et pour
les cp c'est aussi pour leur donner
envie de lire quand ils seront plus
grands
alors commençons seulement gueuler eux
ce projet bah justement c'est organisé
sur deux mois où on a coupé la classe en
plusieurs petits groupes on a révisé
quatre histoires différentes et on a
présenté à trois auditoires différents
deux classes de cp et un auditoire
composé de nos parents et petits frères
petite soeur explique très bien se dire
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cet
appareil parce que vous voyez pas un
bout de mon but fait inquiète apparu
dans le décor sais tu sais c'est quoi
cet appareil que le cadre en bois se
nomme un but et y est ça sert à comment
un but et vous connaissez c'est bon ça
me rassure pour un coût de la bouteille
but we abou taille est d'accord d'accord
et ses pouvoirs à l'intérieur oui cette
histoire l'intérieur a cédé ken ishii
bailly colas assima jolie tatata le
caniche quoi kamishibaï kamishibaï
équipe
photo cl plutôt asiatiques alors bon
explique expliqué malo j'en suis sûr
c'est quoi le kamishibaï c'est
une c'est des histoires japonaise et ça
veut dire théâtre de papier
ouais c'est ce que j'ai là en fait c'est
ça c'est les histoires à l'intérieur du
questeur les c'est ça a paru au viiie
siècle et c'était des moines bouddhistes
qui le lisent est au rose il est trés
pour transmettre des morales j'espère
qu'on va le voir l'image parce que on
l'a mis là voilà pour je pense que je
pense qu'on tourne les panneaux c'est ça
c'est ça ouais et les textes juste
derrière d'accord ok ça sert à quoi ça
va la transmettre
souvent parlé au point ça c'est super
d'être des 8 me c'est une morale à la
fin ouais
oui parce que des choses écrites
derrière comme ça on peut avoir l'image
en face me présente l'image haut à
l'auditoire et non un texte juste
derrière pour leur lien d'accord donc si
je récapitule la petite chose en bois là
c'est le castellet en bois ça s'appelle
le bouteille mais j'ai bien compris et
l'histoire c'est à dire ce que je suis
en train de tourner là c'est le
kamishibaï kamishibaï ça les fait
beaucoup sourire parce que vous vous
brossez dessus depuis combien de temps
de moore c'est ça mais nous ça fait dix
secondes qu'on bosse dessus ça nous
paraît un peu étrange
il ya plein d'histoires effectivement
d'ailleurs je peux pas tout dire mais
oui qu'est-ce qu'on va retenir des mots
mal aux dents celle ci c'est maya plein
de la plainte d'expression avec des
animaux à l'intérieur comme comme ce
qu'on voit là oui c'est normal avec des
amis sur la photo c'est très bien allez
on va terminer avec vos impressions ça
s'est passé comment là comment comment
ça s'est passé quand vous avez présenté
ça à vos camarades de jeu c'était plutôt
bien ça nous a permis d'avoir une
relation avec les cp voile et ça fait un
peu l' inverse quand de trois albums de
trois albums c'est plutôt les 6e et 5e
ou plutôt les grands qui sont les
adultes il hisse au 6e ou 5e et au cm1
cm2 et nous c'est plutôt l'inversé
plutôt les 4e qui vont lire à des cp et
transmettre dans l'autre sens l'envié de
lire elle est en tout cas c'est très
bien vous avez fait travailler l'oral et
vous
être à l'aise comme on dit devant un
public avec notamment le qualifie by
merci à tous les nouveaux reste avec
nous jusqu'à la fin